so I'm curious what was your very first
reaction when Jim pitched your return in
this movie to you did you ever see that
coming or was it completely out of left
field it was kind of out of left field
it was because you know I
I knew I I died he was so big and bad in
in that in the first one and and the
death seemed so definitive it seemed to
me that uh it was just thrilling to the
idea of uh him being reconstituted and
and coming back and uh and developing
too because there'd be no point in
bringing him back if he was the same
thing you know but uh regrouping in hell
as we say and and and bringing and
coming and and you know trying it again
so in the movie we get to see OG
quarridge leave that message for his
recomm self and I was curious if you
ever spoke to Jim about what it was like
when OG quarrett was even asked to do
that to begin with because he would
essentially be agreeing to becoming the
thing that he despised most so did you
ever figure out what his reaction might
have been I don't think he he I don't
think first of all he does he does it as
it's it's all a hypothetical to him this
is an exercise to him it's like Parker
Salford said oh yeah we got to do this
thing you got to make this thing and I'm
going what what's the point it's a waste
of my time I'm going to go out there I'm
gonna get the G no no no no you got to
do this Miles because uh it's company
policy all right I mean read your
contract you know so it's all right fine
we'll do it you know all right I'll do
it and I do it and I kind of and I and
you know like anything when he does it
he kind of gets into it for a minute and
but he doesn't he's not considering the
implications the whole thing is so if
this happens and it ain't gonna happen
you know but uh of course it's prophetic
isn't it until it does and it makes for
a very interesting sequel for that
character so when you're playing the
recumb version of him what is something
that you wanted to retain from the
original Quarry to make sure that we
understood that there's a deep
connection there but also what is
something you wanted to do to make us
believe that like yes they are the same
people but he's also not he is his own
kind of being in a sense yeah well I
mean I it it's not not something that
you plan so much hopefully it
organically emerges from the from from
the what's what what you're doing from
the from the from the script from the
new work but of course look his sense of
uh uh Mission his uh his sort of just
his Relentless you know pursuit of
whatever agenda it is that he has at any
time I think that that remains
completely intact with courts you know
but I think that but obviously there are
changes and those changes are somewhat
mysterious because what what it is it's
that it's the DNA it's the way of water
has kind of entered into him as as well
and um and those are so there are things
happening him that he can't account for
and he's not really used to this is a
guy who lived his life in straight lines
things those lines are now getting real
sinewy okay so here's here's my
follow-up to that do you think that
recom quarrich is redeemable does he
have a chance of potentially learning
lessons and becoming a better person
Avatar going forward
I think it's that
one should always remain open to the the
possibilities who can who can say I mean
this is a Mysterious World AWOL Works in
strange ways and and and will he nil he
he is part of that world now what he has
learned is that he cannot shape that
world according to his his uh desires
his the way he wants to do things he
needs to adapt to it and so I think
under those circumstances anything is
possible do I think personally think
that he's redeemable
yeah sure will he be redeemed can't say
Okay so the next question I have to ask
to that though is is OG quartz
redeemable if he had survived would you
have had the same faith in him or is it
a different situation it's a different
situation here it's it it's a tough
question but I mean the the uh the OG uh
uh uh Colonel uh he had cauterized away
so much of uh his uh uh emotion and
feeling he was he'd put him he was in a
tough spot just uh spiritually it seems
to be I believe it this is how I
interpreted it I felt it that way I want
like a whole Bible on how the whole
recumb works and the percentage of
something believe me I'm sure that it
will appear in the fan you know
eventually in fandom they'll do the
whole thing you know